than
this
you're wrong no no
no
right good morning um we've had a bit of
turnover in the committee this last
month or so
so for those who don't know represent
vanti is
replacing representative Wilhelm
permanently um further
not let's let's just say there's not an
expiration date on her
appointment uh representative bom is
filling in for
Representative no not well Dolan fine
who who is has a conflict representative
Dunn is filling in for one of our new
members representative abar has left the
committee because of the workload she
has been replaced by representative
Carol Brown who is currently out after
knee surgery he will be with us in
January and represent brassy is in for
representative goalie who has health
issues today our newest member
representative Boyd
uh by my fault I left I forgot to remind
him of the executive session and
therefore he will be late um if there's
some issues we will take a break if
necessary and when he till he gets here
and representative s is
here okay
and I think that's all the changes for
today
um
all right so I think I'm going to start
at the top of the
list make it easy for everybody to find
where we
are um on House Bill
105 representative groda you have a
motion yes um I'd move itl on House Bill
105 is there a
second uh representative Schmidt okay I
do you wish to speak to your motion
representative
gr yes um the intention my intention was
to um work on this bill over the
summer and it became evident that coming
to a
consensus was not going to be easily
attained so I think we should just put
this away for some other
day Okay do you wish to speak to your
second representative
okay does anyone else have any comments
or
questions yeah I will I will mention
that the people in the industry that got
involved had were not unanimous in
support by any means and in fact many of
them didn't want any um oversight at
all so until they figure that out
themselves it didn't seem appropriate to
proceed with this
registration anyone
else all right the motion is itl on
House Bill
105 the clerk can call the RO when he's
ready representative Simon yes
representative lakas yes
okay representative Bailey yes
representative sanon staso yes represen
Dolan
represent either bom or dun whichever
you prefer oh okay okay represent B
yes um I got
old is it
we got an old sheet I
apologize representive Dunn yes
representive
Gard yes clerk vot yes representive groa
yes representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie or grassy grassy
yes
sorry representative Shu yes
representative O'Brien yes
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick
yes representative Gould not
here representative Smith
yes representative manga py yes and the
chair yes 19 yay z n that can't be right
there's two people missing oh oh
18 this is is um yes I got to fix
this 18 y
18 okay yeah right representative school
does not here yet and neither is
Representatives apologize I have to fix
these sheets here
okay all right is there any objection to
consent okay seeing none so represent C
your court is at your earliest
convenience all right
ALS Bill
183 relative to the employment of
retired firefighters at the fire
academy representative Simon thank you
madam chair I'd like to move itl on
hb13 is there a
second representative uh laus
seconds do you wish to speak to your
motion um sure um and looking at this
bill uh I think we've determined that um
it really really affects a very small
number of people and this isn't really a
a door that we want to open um and start
a conversation in other areas it just
seems better to leave things as they are
and and the fire academy will have to
seek another
solution represent laus do you wish to
speak to your second uh no thanks okay
I'd like to to comment that I got from
the retirement system a report on how
many hours retirees are
working and the average for everybody is
537 hours the average for firefighters
is less than
500 so running into the 1300
hours that um that's the limit sorry
1352 is only going to be a very few
people what's that so I I can give that
to people it was really enlightening
that we
we struggle to to put a limit on it when
there are actually very few retirees
that are working enough hours to make a
difference yeah there's not enough
copies for everybody but you can at
least uh share the
information anyone else have a comment
or a
question all
right seeing none the motion is
inexpedient to legislate and the clerk
can call the
role representative Simon yes
representative lakas yes representative
Bailey yes representative santon staso
yes representative bone yes
representative Dunn yes representative
Gard yes clerk votes yes representative
groda read ently yes representative
Schmidt yes representative Grazy yes
representative sht yes representative
O'Brien yes representative Davis yes
representative Fitzpatrick
yes representative
Smith
manuti
yes oh
represent gold very reluctantly yes and
the chair
yes I said I got 20 19 really I
represent boy oh that's right she she
walked and okay 19 yay zero n okay all
right that's is there any objection to
consent see seeing none we'll put that
one on
consent all
right house bill
274 I move ought to pass with Amendment
and I present amendment
number
um
22938 which you should all have a copy
of I second
okay all right and I will we had a
hearing on the amendment on
Monday what this does is
remove basically everything that was
originally in House Bill
274 because some of it was included in
House Bill 357 which
passed and some of it is had it had
major issues the part about the
committee taking action in place of the
whole house has some constitutional
questions
and I'm not sure enough that it's
correct that to want to fight it so I
took that part
out a number of agencies needed to be
removed from the bill because they are
not actually state
agencies they are deliberately separate
from the state government in order to
get Federal money like the housing
um whatever the housing authority and um
some other lending
agencies
um they cannot fall under the our
rulemaking Authority without violating
their status as independent
agencies so they have been removed there
were um if any of you remember either of
the hearings we held on that bill they
all came out in force to tell us
so so I agreed with them what the
amendment let put in is a little bit
more of legislative oversight or at
least hopefully legislative
oversight it requires when the notices
go
out in all cases they send it to known
stakeholders which is not defined but if
the agency doesn't know who cares about
their rules they ought to and they
should send all of them notice of new of
these new
rules and if there is new legislation
involved the agency sends notice of the
rule to the
legislature in particular
the legislative leadership and the
chairs of the
appropriate uh policy
committees we can't force them to
actually pay attention to the rules but
we can at least make sure they get a
notice and that's what that does
and also it adds if
the rule is it is objected to by jail
car without going to a final objection
without going to a joint
resolution thank you I
was yes on the final OB objection no on
the joint
resolution they can adopt the agency can
adopt the rule but it needs to prove
that it meets legislative
intent and this says that in that rare
case and they lose the agency pays the
plaintiff's legal costs which will help
encourage people to uh to challenge a
rule and I got
information which I sent to you on the
number of final objections and joint
resolutions um for final
objections there there was one in 2013
and one in
2019 and that's
it for joint
resolutions there's been only one since
11 which was in 2019 which
um there was no legislative action taken
on the rule on the
resolution so these are very rare
occurrences we don't need to worry that
the agencies are going to get sued over
their rules every weekend it just that
if they do adopt a rule
without over the objection of jail car
then and they lose then they have to pay
so I think that's a fairly
minor um
penalty representative Brer do you wish
to speak to your second I do thank you
madam chair what I support about this
amendment is that it does loop in the
legislative committees I think that
often times when we write legislation we
lose sight of the fact that that's
really only half the work the rest of it
has to do with rule making and it's
important that those rules represent the
legislative intent and that this is a is
a step in that
direction anyone else have a comment
what representative
Schmid thank you madam chair so
um I think that the informational aspect
that you talked about early on in your
remarks uh is can only be beneficial to
the degree that stakeholders are better
informed about um you know upcoming
rules and so forth and therefore able to
participate if they have issues they're
welcome to do so at the present moment
uh but to the degree that they don't
know about the issue they obviously uh
are not going to show up uh so the
informational aspect I think can only
benefit the process with regard to the
um the number of final objections and
joint
resolutions uh as a 17-year member of
the Jael car uh I was pretty sure that
the number was going was going to be
extremely small and one of the reasons
is um that the agencies are very
reluctant to um to go into that uh um
you know um Gauntlet of
uh of implementing a rule that the
legislature has put a final that the jel
car has put a final objection on um
because they're asking uh to be sued and
and to have no support from the state uh
so I think it it's extremely unlikely
that we're going to see a number of such
instances uh and to the degree that that
that we
do this can only be uh um you know
beneficial so I think even though it's
not likely to go into effect I mean to
to be in in uh in action very
often better to have a safety net the
time the acrobat Falls than have none at
all so uh I will be supportive of the
amendment thank you representative Gart
thank you madam chair the notice
occupational license shall be made by US
mail just clarifying who's covering that
sorry so on the first page when it says
that the notices will be mailed as well
electronically bolt in or newsletter so
it doesn't have to be
mailed
yes it um they could also just post it
in
the uh gray pages of the union leader
but that's generally not very effective
um there's no newspaper they
not if you do you want to know how this
actually done in case of
lies that an no I was more oh no I was
just more concerned about the cost but
it's it's a cost of doing
business representative laus so I I
think the answer is just oplc pays for
it out of you know the money money they
collect it's one of the costs of doing
business for for lienes is sending out
Ru making
notices
uh I believe that they do send as many
out by email as they can but uh not not
not everybody has email these
days it's very few any other questions
or
concerns okay then the motion is on
amendment
2393 to House Bill
representative Simon yes representative
lakas yes representative Bailey yes
representative sanon aaso yes
representative B yes representative Dunn
yes representative geard yes clerk vote
Yes representative groa yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative grassy yes representative
Shu yes representative O'Brien yes
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative Gould yes
representative Smith yes representative
mapy yes and the chair yes 19 y zero nay
okay in that case I move on to pass with
amendment I
second any further
discussion probably not since the
amendment placed the bill
uh motion is ought to pass with
Amendment 2293 on House Bill 274 and the
clerk can call the role representative
Simon yes representative leakas yes
representative Bailey yes representative
santon staso yes representative B yes
representative Dunn yes representative
ghard yes clerk votes yes representative
groda yes representative Schmidt yes
representative grassy yes representative
Shu yes representative ran yes
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative Gould yes
representative Smith yes representative
mapy yes and the chair yes 19 yay Z are
there any objections to
consent all right seeing none we'll put
that one on consent
also all right house bill 428 relative
mental health practice represent of
blackis I'd like to move uh itl on this
bill okay is there a
second
okay you wish to speak to your motion I
do um so all of the contents of this
bill were included in Senate Bill 207
which uh passed the legislature signed
by the governor and became
law um there had been some discussion
about an amendment to include the Mental
Health compact uh the committee never
acted on it and uh representative
Shapiro who wanted that has introduced
it as an LSR so we'll probably be seeing
it again next year and that's it
represent Smith do you wish to speak to
your
second you did second it do you wish to
speak no okay does anyone wish to speak
on on on House Bill
428 comments
questions okay in that case the motion
is inexpedient to legislate on House
Bill 428 and the cour can call the role
representative Simon yes representative
lakas yes representative Bailey yes
representative santon staso yes
representative B yes representative Dunn
yes representative gearhard yes clar
quot yes representative gr yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative grassy yes representative
Shu yes representative O'Brien yes
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative Gould yes
representative Smith yes representative
maputi yes and the chair yes 19 y0
N any objection to
consent all right seeing none we'll put
it on consent and thank you
representative leus for your committee
report all right house bill
449 president of Simon you have a motion
yes thank you madam chair I move itl on
HB
449 all second okay do you wish to speak
to your motion um yes um 449 was a bill
that we retained um well we kind of
waited to see what happened with HB uh
436 um dealing with group two retirement
benefits um that bill is now being
looked at by the retirement commission
and coming up with a recommendation on
how to move forward so um this bill is
no longer necessary for anything so
we're recommending I at this point
represent
BR I have nothing to add
okay as part of the retirement
commission we think it would make more
sense to attach our fix to house bill
for
4 um 436 itself which was retained in
finance because that's already been
approved by the house once and
so if the finance committee approves
what the rec uh retirement commission
recommends it can go to the floor in
January and then be voted on there and
then go to the Senate um so the
commission is vigorously pursuing
various options that they think can get
strong support in both the house and the
Senate and I think having one bill to
move forward rather than two would make
things a lot
easier
okay anyone
else okay seeing none the motion is
inexpedient to legislate on House Bill
around no no it's one that's coming
up oh sorry about sorry about the
confusion that's just being
proactive
okay so the motion is inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill 449 and the
clerk can call the RO representative
Simon yes representative lakas yes
representative Bailey yes representative
santon staso yes representative B yes
representative Dunn yes representative
ghard yes clerk votes yes representative
groa yes representative Schmidt yes
representative grassy yes representative
Shu yes representative O'Brien yes
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative ghl yes
representative Smith yes represent pres
Manti yes and the chair yes 19 yay Z nay
okay is there any objection to
consent all right seeing none we'll put
that one on
consent okay House Bill
518 representative
groa yes um Madam chair on Monday we had
a hearing for an amendment to House Bill
518 and the comments there were some
grammatical errors made in the amendment
so in front of you is the revised
Amendment which is
2426 and I move Amendment
2426 okay I'll second
that do you wish to speak to your motion
yes thank you so during the summer I
mean during the Spring you might recall
that um this committee did a lot of work
on House Bill 65
5 and in tandem with House Bill 2 so one
of the issues that we did we handled was
um addressing the rather large house
bill 655 and making sure that it was
harmonious with what was in House Bill
2 um in addition so there were
some little Schnebly left Parts left
that we needed to be tidied up and House
Bill 518 addresses that specifically IT
addresses
the issuances of licenses which are Now
function of the office as opposed to the
board it also includes the
disciplinary
um
uh disciplinary um responsibility of the
office and the board and I think that's
the the Crux of the
amendment yes
the the issue that we discussed on
Monday was what happens when when
licenses are expiring and we esta and
this language now establishes that there
is a 60-day notice prior to
expiration and as long as the renewal
application is received in that 60 days
the license
continues and is pro until it is issued
if the renewal request comes in after
the 60 days
but within a year it can be reinstated
without further penalty but they are
practicing without a license for the
period of the lapse which could be
anything from a weekend to uh almost a
year and at that point it might be
subject to
discipline
but it seemed reasonable to us to
establish those guidelines
because various boards had various other
definitions of when the license expired
when they renewal had to be in and what
you had to do to U continue your license
and so this establishes a standard
policy for all the boards which was uh
appreciated does anyone else have
comments or
questions representative
Schmidt thank you madam chair so I
wonder whether uh because I don't recall
this question was asked uh on Monday uh
whether this is in point of fact a
relatively common or relatively uncommon
uh event that somebody um neglects to uh
renew their license and therefore that
they are technically practicing without
a license uh whether this is something
that oplc has any kind of information on
well it's convenient director Courtney
do you have a response to
that thank
you thank you madam chair thank you for
their question Lindsay Courtney
executive director
oplc um I don't have specific numbers in
front of you I would say it's very
profession specific uh it's very common
with licensed nursing assistance um it's
also very common with real estate
salespersons um in the past I think in
the professions that allowed late
renewal it's also fairly common um some
of the technical professions but then
other professions are very good about
renewing on time I would say Allied
Health falls into that bucket
um question Madam chair yes thank you
for that previous answer uh director uh
so um I if you can get good adherence
from certain professions and poor
adherence from some other professions
are you undertaking any efforts to try
to uh either wrap them on the knuckles
or uh larger
print so they so they don't uh do that
because it's not a good idea obviously
to have that sloppy adherence or
compliance so what are you doing to try
to ameliorate the
situation well I think our position is
that it's it's in Upon A licy to renew
their license on time we provide
notification um and then if they
practice without a license that is
subject to discipline by the board I
won't you know I don't want to
stereotype professions but there there's
a culture involved with certain
professions as opposed to others that um
may make more
professions um uh encourage them to Ren
their licenses on time um particularly
in healthcare we often see that the
employer is monitoring it because
obviously they can't be reimbursed for
payment um if the provider or the
healthcare practitioner is not license
so when we speak to alenas they usually
find out that their license is expired
because their employer has told them
they can't show up for work um so that's
another mechanism for internal controls
that doesn't exist in um other
professions that don't have that
reimbursement piece and and I understand
that with real estate a AG there's a lot
of turnover and so somebody may not
renew their license not expecting to be
active and then they got a commission so
they say well I better get my license in
yes
corrects thank you I think that helps
those any other questions or concerns
thank you
director anyone
else all right and I will say that this
very thoughtful letter we got is
irrelevant because because it deals with
the content of the original House Bill
518 which has been totally removed by
this
amendment and and and in fact I will say
that the content of House Bill 518 which
was a study committee was felt that the
the pharmacist
and um other professionals can should
work it out themselves and not bother us
about
it anyone
else okay that case the motion is to
adopt Amendment 2426 H to House Bill 518
and the clerk can call the
role representative Simon yes
representative lakus yes representative
Bailey yes representative Santo nasso
yes representative bom yes
representative Dunn yes representative
Gard yes clerk votes yes representative
groa yes representative Schmidt yes
representative grassy yes representative
Shu yes representative O'Brien yes
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative Gould yes
representative Smith yes representative
manuti yes and the chair yes 19 y z
nesa I move house sorry I move otpa on
House Bill 518 amended with number
24 26 H and I'll
second okay any further discussion
comments
questions all
right in that case the clerk call the
rule the motion is ought to pass with
Amendment representative Simon yes
representative lakas yes representative
Bailey yes representative sanon aaso yes
representative bone yes representative
Dunn yes representative dick
ghard uh my name
H clerk vote Yes representative groa yes
representative shimit yes representative
grassy yes representative Shu yes
representative O'Brien yes
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative Gould yes
representative Smith yes representative
Manti yes and the chair yes 19 y your
nay okay motion passes is there any
objection to
consent all right we'll put that one on
consent and since representative Boyd is
not here yet I'd like to skip over to
Senate Bill
106 and ask representative broer for a
motion yes I move OTP on House Bill on
Senate Bill 106 and I'll second
okay represent BR do you wish to speak
on it yes um this bill um was brought to
us because there was a need for
certifying um there need to be a
professional certification for child
care
programs and it seemed that there were
rules that were going to be written on
this matter but those rules were not
written and it did not seem that there
would be an intention to write the rules
so unfortunately we're putting this in
law represent leus um yes I mean I agree
with all that it's um they wrote a long
and uh interesting non-responsive uh
response to us um I thought since they
had statutory authority to do all of the
uh child care licensing and they did it
for everything else it should be
consistent they should have done it
which is um you know why I didn't
support this originally but given their
response um I regretfully support
this represent grassic yes thank you uh
Madam chairperson and the members who
supported this bill this is certainly an
important bill when it comes to the
workers in child care uh this is a CR
issue which could have been simply done
through HHS by changing some of their
standards and they you know sitting in
rules simple uh they haven't done it
this allows uh kids who are taking these
programs in CTE programs at high school
level to utilize that credentialing
those credits uh to increase their
salaries and to better themselves in
their field when you have kids that are
coming out of high school that are
committed to working in child care it's
very rare these days and it's very
important that we support them and since
HHS is dragging their feet we need to
push
them thank you anyone
else I I I agree that that's the
issue the these credentials are not
mandatory they're optional but they're
respected in the field and they're worth
in the case of this emerging
professional it's worth $2 an hour which
is a lot considering that these people
are coming in at extremely low rates of
pay for the most
part so and since HHS has had the
Authority for better than 10 years to
write rules defining them and they
haven't bothered to do so and they
didn't bother to update their their
standards which are available on the
website but not adopted as
rules
uh we feel they're being non-responsive
and it's time to take it in hand I I
would personally have preferred that we
actually establish those credentials in
statute since they're not bothering to
put them in rule but there were too many
other things for me to take it on and no
one else was was
volunteering so at this point all we're
doing is saying that the child care CTE
certificate is the same as an emerging
professional certificate and the uh
employer should honor it and I hope it
helps and I wish that HHS would
uh
take if they're establishing these
things they should do it properly and
not just sort of under the table which
is the way they're doing it
now anyone
else thank you thank you all right in
that case the motion is ought to pass on
H Senate Bill 106 and the clerk call the
role representative Simon yes
representative lakas yes representative
Bailey yes representative santon naso
yes representative B yes representative
nun yes representative geard yes CL vote
Yes representative groa yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative grassy yes representative
Shu yes representative O'Brien yes
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative gold yes
representative Smith yes representative
mapy yes and the chair yes 19 y0 N all
right any objections to
consent seeing none all right
um House Bill
644 representative
lais you have a motion yes um
let me get back to it I'd like to move
um ought to pass with an amendment and
that amendment is um
24368 is there a
second second second of repres the gold
all right M
chair I think we are kind of trampling
on a proper procedure uh in one respect
and I'd like to see uh either that we
see he's doing that so in situations
such as this the appropriate motion is
to state that there will be an amendment
and the move ought to pass on the
amendment if it if it passes then we've
got a situation where we can have otpa
you can't move otpa until you got okay
the amendment adopted
soed small matter but let's do it right
it's up over over the summer I've
forgotten okay do you wish to speak to
your motion to adopt Amendment 2436 I'll
I'll speak to the amendment first and um
so there were um two and and I had
emailed out an earlier Amendment and I
apologize it there are two sections that
need to be removed and the one I sent
but through email only removed one of
them and the uh paper I dropped on
people's desk I just got this morning
the amendment uh removes the two
sections and those were related to
um
the situation where if a booth is being
rented uh within an existing
Salon that it didn't require a whole
separate Salon license just for the
booth and um that you find it here sorry
I I have a quick question on that did we
not discuss this in House Bill two
exactly that's why we're taking it out
of this
one okay so it is in house bill too um
it actually was included in in House
Bill
409 okay I knew that we had talked about
this before yeah so we're taking it out
of this one because we already have it
in something elsea right it was included
in House Bill 409 which has become law
and so this would just be a duplicate so
you're talking about removing 5B section
5B let me which is the section five in
this
amendment it's yes section five and six
in the original bill
um right because those are both well
that was done in 409 and
actually did print a copy of
409 yes sa section five deletes RSA 313
A9 Roman B
which
says um that a booth license is
required right and the um section six is
the one that um explicitly says boots
attached or within a salon or barber
shop that are Opera independently shall
be subject to a lure in the same manner
but that but 409 takes that
out okay well if I read 5B it says hire
employ or rent to Booth to any person to
engage in a practice regulated by this
chapter unless such person then holds a
valid license or temporary permit issued
by the board so it's hire employee or
ventor Booth any person to engage
correct um in in where where are you
reading that from I'm reading 5B well
what section from which I'm reading I'm
sorry I'm reading from the from 644 okay
right but in 409 which became law it's
got for 313 A9
2B if that's the same
section and I believe in 409 it just
says hire employee or otherwise allow
actually it's oh okay so I understand I
okay thank you yeah yeah okay yeah it's
a little confusing what's with what yeah
yeah yeah I but I I agree okay and then
six
uh the language that's in six is
identical to what's in uh section of
409 so 6 two remains any licensed Barber
shall upon written application
accompanied by receive a license to
operate a salon a barber shop or mobile
barber shop in the state yes it it
that's what establishes the need for a
shop license right and that is not
changed yeah the the text the text
that's in 64 4 section 6 is identical to
the text that got included in uh 409 in
the chaptered final version 235 col 6
it's exactly the same language which was
adopted so there's no need for us to do
it
again yes representa ass Maybe by by way
of clarification so RSA
313a as written in law already contains
that language is that where it landed
you know what RSA had ended up in um
yeah 3 313 a 19 uh2 yeah so taking it
out of this doesn't remove it from the
RSA it's just taking it out of this bill
correct I mean the changes the changes
that 644 makes in in particular removing
Part B about booths is already removed
uh by by 409 okay and I don't know
what's actually up on gen Court I found
they're updating the rsas there very
slowly so it's still it's still saying
that people
who don't have a license
this can do the original bill you 644
with 644 the so 6 now that we've
establish what the amendment does which
is just take those components out of the
bill that were already in other
statutes the remainder of it remains
correct and i' suggest we vote on this
and then we can have the discussion on I
agree so yes I'll support the amendment
representative goul do you wish to speak
to your second no I think everything's
been
said okay anyone else have a comment on
the
amendment okay so the motion is to adopt
Amendment 2436 H to House Bill
644 and the clerk can call the
RO representative Simon yes
representative lakus yes representative
Bailey yes representative santon naso
yes representative bom yes
representative Dunn yes representative
geard yes clerk votes yes representative
groa yes representative Schmidt yes
representative grassy yes representative
sht yes representative O'Brien yes
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative Gould yes
representative Smith yes representative
manati yes and the chair yes 19 y z n
okay so we have adopted the amendment
and the representative lus so I'd like
to move um on House Bill 644 ought to
pass with
amendment is there a
second second
okay you we should speak to your motion
representative I do
um okay I mean we we've uh talked about
this a lot when earlier um so we took
that out and what this this does is it
drops the requirement for license for um
the things that are called blow drying
for one that's shampooing conditioning
dying that kind of thing um makeup
application and the eyebrow threading um
but you still need to have a license to
do anything with chemicals dying
bleaching cutting anything where you got
you know sharp implements or any of that
um and you know my argument is New
Hampshire has a greater training
requirement for a license to do this
sort of thing than most other states and
U you know the large cost in time and
expense to get a license is you know
particular burden on people that I mean
they may not be in a great economic
situation they're trying to get some
extra income they may have
responsibilities for taking care of kids
or whatever and I don't see any
justification for the state limiting
what people can do to earn a living
other than you know significant impact
on public health and safety and I you
know we've I know there's some there's
been some vague concerns I've heard but
but really I don't think any of these
pose any kind of significant risk um and
so I don't think there's a justification
for requiring a license and and it's not
just you know my idea on this um 40 of
the other states have an exemption for
some are all of these services including
all of our neighboring states and I
haven't heard of uh you know a rash of
bad things happening as a result um
you I've also heard concern raised that
you know letting people provide these
services without a license might put
them in a position where their customers
are going to ask them to do things that
would require license and they might
feel they need to yield to that and I
understand that but couple of things um
I mean people may can always break the
law whether it's this law or any
other and you know I don't see
justification in limiting the freedom or
the ability to earn living of people who
are following the law just because
somebody else might break it um yeah I
mean if you follow that logic you know
probably couldn't let people uh be
permitted to do much of anything um and
so I I don't see that as a um a
legitimate argument the other thing that
this bill would do is exemp makeup
application and and similar uh sorts of
things so it could be somebody doing a
demonstration at a department store or
the other thing is is you can have um
you know uh people come to shoot a movie
here they may want to use their own
makeup people uh same thing uh given
this season you have political
candidates come in and and they end up
getting makeup on before they end up on
TV and now if they want to use their own
people they have to go through the
trouble of getting licens in New
Hampshire you know for what might be a
single appearance um and that doesn't
seem again like it's uh a significant
Improvement you know in public safety
because those people are work with and
are hired by you know whoever is getting
the services so that that doesn't seem
to make sense so anyway that's why I uh
I ask people to support aop pass uh with
the amendment okay represent gou do you
wish to speak to your second yes thank
you madam chair having attended
cosmetology school I know firsthand that
there is very little technical education
given on how to wash hair so uh I just
don't understand any reason why it would
require a licensed cosmetologist to wash
hair a friend of mine recently shared a
shampoo boy video clip which is a
humorous thing but um we ought to be
allowing people to enter the field and
do that um I believe it's still legal I
haven't researched this and I'm sure my
colleagues will correct me if I'm wrong
but I believe it's still legal in New
Hampshire to um to train at in bar
barbering and
cosmetology um under an apprenticeship
situation and so being allowed to
shampoo hair and do those kinds of
things is um an important way for an
apprentice to be able to earn a living
while they're learning and apprenticing
I think that it's really important for
um not only Workforce entry to allow
people opportunities to work that would
be denied we certainly heard from the
hairdressing salons that they're having
a hard time filling these positions and
so this would help them
but it also uh in my experience working
with the elderly there comes a point and
in hairdressing school we learned that
um there comes a point for elderly
people where washing your hair can be
extremely difficult and eventually you
have a nurse's aid who's coming into the
home to assist the elderly by allowing
blowout bars and
independent um facilities to be
established where the where the elderly
can go and have their hair done at a
more affordable cost because it's not
having requiring a license and all the
recruitments that go with it to wash
somebody's hair and blow dry it can
allow elderly especially women which is
my interest but it would be true for men
too to have um some dignity in the aging
process and continue to feel some
Independence and and important things so
for all those reasons I strongly support
this Bill thank you okay I think
representative Schmidt has a question
representative
Schmid uh thank you madam chair so uh
I I don't disagree with what's been said
up to this point with regard to things
like shampooing and blow drying and and
styling and so forth I think that is um
I I I don't disagree with that the
problem I have is that the uh
aesthetician profession and and this spe
the testimony that we've heard
previously not today but previously with
regard to um the subject of eye makeup
or threading is I think a different
situation when you have people who may
have little to no training who may be
completely acceptable in terms of
washing hair uh styling hair blow drying
and so forth and so on when you get them
monkey around with in the in the
immediate proximity of the eye which is
where the eyebrow is located it's right
there
uh and hygiene is one of the things that
we've heard and I've been on this
committee for 17 years uh and we've
dealt with esthetician issues before and
uh and the idea that when you have
people who are uh untrained so it's not
a question of what representative leus
was referring to earlier where
um people can break the law yes they can
break the law about all kinds of things
things U to the degree that they
intentionally
knowingly do something they steal they
harm a person intentionally
knowingly that we all recognize when you
do that you're taking the law on your
own hands and you should be treated
accordingly um in this and where but
where ignorance is involved uh and
hygiene is is in many cases a question
of ignorance uh people don't know uh the
we had a situation with a president many
years ago um President Garfield was shot
uh by a disappointed office
Seeker he died months later not from the
effect of the bullet I think it's widely
recognized not from the effect of the
bullet but the point that the that the
Physicians who came in to treat him
stuck their unwashed fingers
into the wound to probe for the
bullet they commonly recognize they they
infected President Garfield and he died
of the cause because of the infection
that the Physicians unknowingly but
ignorantly um so when you're dealing
with the
eyes because you're going to be right
there if you're doing this threading
thing um or any other makeup application
and so forth there I think uh it's not a
question of knowingly violating the law
or or doing something unsafe they don't
know and if they don't have training
who's going to tell them so I I can't
support the bill because it allows
something that I think is inherently
potentially dangerous so I will not be
supporting this bill as long as it has
got estheticians in there thank
you thank you
represent
BR
um in the bill it says in
chapter in
paragraph let me just be sure paragraph
seven part five the owner of the salon
Barbershop or mobile Barbershop license
under this section shall be responsible
for verifying the education training
skill and competence of persons who work
in the owner's salon barber shop and
mobile barber
shop
so what are the education training
skills and competence of people how is
that going to be
measured representative
laas okay this uh section that's in here
um I don't think is specific
to you know a blow dry bar or or that
sort of thing because I mean it it
doesn't even that doesn't require a sh
shop license and it's interesting that
this got included in here but if
somebody does have a shop license then
they are you know then they're supposed
to uh be responsible for what happens in
there and you know for someone who is
doing what's permitted in here without a
license the things are pretty basic it
would be you know as was mentioned um
sanitation and that sort of thing and
that's something that you know the uh
salon owner is has got to be familiar
with so I mean it's it's very basic
things but they're still important
things so how do we make sure that
that's
done that's a responsibility of the
employer yeah however oplc enforcement
does it I assume if they go into a salon
they either get reports or there for
some other reason and notice that
there's things being done that people
shouldn't be doing or they're doing it
you know in a way that would endanger
people they would take AC action but if
you're removing the licensing for people
who have blow drrive bars there's no
reason for oplc to go in there correct
in that case that's correct and my
argument is that the um the risk of
these things is low and that's not I
mean I understand that people can
imagine bad things happening um and it's
not just my you know panish view that
nothing bad is going to happen vast
majority of states are not requiring
licenses for this sort of thing and I
haven't heard of a rash of problems and
I think the threshold for acquiring a
license has got to be you know a a
really a a very real risk to public
health and safety and not something
that's is sort of theoretical or Could
Be Imagined um and so that's my take on
forther followup followup and then on
line just you know on on two comma b
line two blow dry styling includes the
use of and D so maybe you want to get
rid of that D where is this on it's uh
2B paragraph one 2B I don't have a
version oh ah okay what what again in
there is it includes the use and and I
don't know what the g
[Music]
means St use use and styling of her um I
think that D in the following space or
prior one is extraneous and I'm hoping
that an enrolled as in enrollment that
would be fixed styling of hair
extensions that's not blow drying what
does that
mean um I might defer to uh someone with
more
experience representative gold uh thank
you that would mean um like curling or
uh using the the brush on the hair
extension to get the style into it
it's it's consistent with washing and
blow drying but it's for not the natural
hair it's for the extension and it's
includes pinning them into place I
presume
correct well there either pinned or
they're glued or they're threaded in but
it's not install excuse me Madam chair
can I follow up please follow up it's
not um discussing applying them it's
discussing styling them if I heard it
correctly I have no further questions
but I will not be supporting the bill
okay any represent gold
I just want to follow up on the
threading which I know has created a
great deal of concern among committee
some committee members and I studied it
extensively I had not heard of it I was
not trained in it and it hasn't been
historically a popular practice um in
the profession what it is is it's a
piece of cotton string and it gets wound
together in such a way that you're just
pulling the hair out with the string and
as someone who spins
yarn fibers uh frequently having hair
like this my hair gets caught up in the
fibers that I'm twisting and it it gets
incorporated into the yarn I'm creating
that's exactly what threading is it's
not getting anywhere near any uh open
tissue you're not sticking your finger
in somebody's eye You're simply taking a
cotton string and with a twisting of the
string your hands are way out far away
from the body the string captures a hair
and pull it out so I just wanted to
clarify on the threading because it's a
unique process that's not commonly
understood um
locally okay repres Mana
py thank you madam chair just uh couple
of comments one is regarding the
threading threading is a very popular uh
in South Asian in know growing up it's
it is it's not very close to the face
and it is uh exactly ly like
representative G uh explained it's and
it's also taught to do it for yourself
so you know it's not something that's
needs professional things so threading
is one just understanding renting a
booth for me it seems like the
responsibility is shifted to the person
who owns the booth if I'm just doing a
blow drying excuse me representative
maputi the booth rental items were
removed from the bill by the amendment
we just recommended thank
you represent
geard thank you madam
chair as far as getting close to
people's faces just a quick comment
concerned what about face painters at
carnival circus kind of things with they
getting close to especially children's
faces they're probably more susceptible
to issues I just I don't see the issue
here I mean I'm just reiterating things
I've already said previously so okay
thank you that is a
concern anyone else have a comment
question Peter Pete representative
Schmid thank you well I I certainly
appreciate the discussion we've gotten
into because um I I know next to nothing
about threading and uh um I I not the
benefit of a beneficiary of uh of any
such treatments um I just yank them out
myself myself when it's a problem um but
but anyway the point is I'm appreciative
of a little bit more instructor I I I do
understand that this is kind of an
started off any way as a somewhat of an
ethic ethnic practice that in certain
cultures it's a common thing to mess
around with your eyebrows for again
probably mostly for ladies um but to the
degree that the makeup aspect and that
that is something where unless you're
using distinctive I don't mean
distinctive distinct um uh packets of
makeup or whatever for customer a then
everything gets thrown away and a new
set of stuff is opened up to be used on
the next customer there's always the
issue of contamination of makeup and so
forth and so on and representative geart
may be unconcerned about what happens
with people getting their faces their
children especially getting their face
pain painted I think if you get an eye
infection or especially um as a result
of it you'd be less sanguin about that
so uh I'm glad to know more but as long
as they're messing around with the eyes
I am not going to support this Bill
thank you representative
gold thank you Madam chair and thank you
representative Schmidt for um for
sharing more about what your concerns
are and certainly having run programs
for teenage girls I dealt with don't
share your makeup as a concern for
infections and passing those kind of
things along in the profession you'll
find like in a hair salon when you buy a
bottle of a product you don't do one use
and toss the product you put the amount
you need need into another container out
of the main Supply and then you apply
from that so you can still apply the
makeup by by taking a small amount and
putting it in a separate little
container you can still be hygienic and
um I I just I agree with what
representative leus has said 40 other
states allow it it's
makeup though um clearly people want to
practice appropriate hygiene it it
doesn't rise to the level of Licensing
in my opinion and I I just wanted to
share that with you thank
you anyone any other
[Music]
comments okay the motion is ought to
pass with Amendment
2436 on House Bill
644 and the clerk can call the
role representative Simon yes
representative leakas yes representative
Bailey yes representative santon naso
yes
representative B yes representative Dunn
yes representative geard yes clerk votes
yes Representative groda
no
representative Schmidt
no representative grassy
no representative Shu no representative
O'Brien no representative Davis no
representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative
gold
yes representative Smith
Smith Representative manuti no and the
chair
yes so it should
be 12a 7
a okay the motion
passes um
is there this will not be on
consent is does someone wish to write a
Minority
Report yes okay representative brto will
write a Minority
Report which will
be your recommendation is
itl yes okay thank you and we'll do
that and
I think we will take a 15minute break
since representative Boyd is not yet
here so we'll take we'll take a break
until
11:25 that will give representative Gro
time to write more commit committee
reports and representative Simon as well
yes Madam chair if I can just say um
thankk you all for the card um I think
many members of the committee know the
uh trials and tribulations I've gone
through in the last year and I guess if
I survive that I can go forward for many
years but thank you all for the
support congratulations on making it so
far and
you'll and there will be a cake
as soon as we get through our work okay
so don't run out too
sooni
we'll take
them whoever
Weil
rule making yes we need to get
together we've entered the
season
yes sure yeah sure I agree as much as
humanly
possible
ring
all right welcome
back introducing representative Bo who
is with us today but and maybe late more
later but definitely for
today the speaker has not yet made an
official pronouncement so we don't know
who our 20th member will
be not the
only ref Schmid I would not attempt to
categorize what we don't
know it would would take too
long okay so House Bill 559
representative Simon you have a
motion uh thank you madam chair I would
like to move um Amendment
246 for consideration by the
committee okay seconded by
representative leus do you wish to speak
to your motion uh yes thank you very
much um really the main uh the only real
change uh that this amendment brings if
the committee members want to look at
page three um starting in line 28 it
really should be bolded I think but it
wasn't so I'll call your attention to it
um it just deals with the contributions
by the employer uh when the bill
originally came around uh I believe it
was 2 and a half% that the uh employer
was going to kick into this defined
contribution plan uh and after further
discussion seemed like everybody who was
involved came to the conclusion that was
just far too small um and so uh an
amendment's been brought forward to
raise that to a minimum of
5% um of the members earnable
compensation and uh we just thought that
that was a much more reasonable starting
place for discussion
so okay representative leus do you wish
to speak to your Amendment uh yes thank
you uh mam chair um you might well first
of all it's not bolded because this is a
whole new section and it's not the
amendment is against current law so
that's why it's not bolded and you might
it might look like it's uh this is
replacing a larger amount of text in the
uh original Bill and that's because the
original Bill
referenced uh the statute for the
defined benefit plan for the employer
contribution in there and uh if you
follow that thread through it's two and
a half per. so actually if we were to
adopt this amendment and this bill the
the uh employer which in this case is
the state U for their group one
employees would actually be uh doubling
the amount that they're paying towards
their retirement
um I know I've been in uh similar plans
in Private Industry through most most of
my career and uh my experience uh for
this kind of plan two and a half percent
is uh is just too low and
uh you know maybe it's too low for the
defined contribution plan but that's a a
uh I mean defined benefit plan but
that's a a different discussion um so
that's the only change and everything
else in here is the same as uh when we
heard this bill earlier this
year okay thank
you anyone else have a comment on the
amendment representative
Shu thank you madam chair um I am um
opposed to this entire bill and I sorry
but I don't think the amendment makes it
that much better to make it acceptable
thank you okay representative Bailey and
then vce
Patrick I guess might would be a
question for representative leakas
when they do this sort of thing don't
they usually cap
it represent laus yes
um the reason that it's uh a what's the
exact language here um equal to or
greater than 5% so that that sets the
floor and um it leaves to the employer
the state in this case the uh the
ability to negotiate as part of the
whole you know contract negotiation
benefits package potentially a number
larger than that now you know ultimately
that spending would have to be approved
by the legislature um so I think I guess
the upper cap on that is is what the
legislature is willing and the governor
is willing to to spend um but at least
that left the flexibility that it could
be another item that was included in uh
contract
negotiation follow
up I guess what I mean is they might say
oh you can do this up to 10% of your
salary or something not not your whole
salary you know um representative leus
yeah in 41k programs usually what
they'll do is they'll have what's called
a match um and
so um the the employer will agree to
match up to some percentage I mean I I
you know for a while I was working some
place where it was 6% so they would
match up to 6% I could contribute more
than that up to some IRS limit um but in
this case this is not a match program
this is um the employer is going to
contribute this
amount um and then also um in the bill
so it would be in statute if it were to
pass is the amount that the employee
pays and right now for the defined
benefit program that's 7% I believe and
it would be the same with this so the
employee would be paying the same amount
and uh and this just addresses the
employer part but it's not the match
Dynamic where the amount the employer is
going to pay is based on the amount you
put in
thank you representative Fitzpatrick are
the amendment changes the employer
contribution from Two and a half to five
is that what yes it changes it from the
same as current group one which is two
and a half% two so and then flat 5% or
more so that's so that's just on the on
the amendment itself and then we will
vote on the overall bill later uh
I will support the amendment because
it's obviously Inc in increasing an
amount that I find is simply uh almost
embarrassing uh I won't support the
overall bill because I believe the 5% is
much too is much too low to be taking
away a defined benef benefit for a
defined contribution I I believe that it
it should be more than 5% %c I also want
to make a a case that the overall
concept is a very positive thing I
believe that uh these programs that
evolved in the 1950s
basically uh when we were the only
economy in the functional economy in the
entire world after World War II and all
of everyone not everyone but many of our
constituents GE IBM you name that they
all had defined benefit plans they don't
have them
anymore and and I don't know how we can
justify to our our citizens that that
we're giving government in in employees
a benefit that is not uh offered to uh
our citizens in the private sector uh
however I do believe that that and the
other positive is that that that uh
these people can take their uh
accumulated cont contributions with them
wherever wherever they uh go so I think
it's a positive but I think we have a
long way to uh uh go to make them fairer
and more attractive thank you madam
chair okay thank you I anyone
else I have uh two comments from the
sponsor who uh has a conflicting
committee from the sponsor who has a
commit conflicting committee meeting
this
morning the impetus for this came out
because he learned that fewer than half
of the state employees reached the
10year limit for
vesting and therefore the defined
contribution the defined benefit plan
was very disad disadvantageous to them
because they contributed while they were
working
and the employer
contributions were not returned to them
when they
left as a fe they haven't reached the
point of investment correct but and like
I said more than half were not reaching
that point so it they were essentially
being used to bulk up the retirement
plan for the long-term employees which
he felt was unfair to the newer people
because they weren't getting any
employer match at all
um and secondly
the in in the
future Lord willing the retirement
system will pay off its unfunded
liabilities and the employer rates will
go down significantly due to paying off
the retirement at that point we have a
statutory requirement that
the employer rate must be at least as
much as the employee rate
uh which is not the case now as has been
commented the employer rate is much
higher on paper because that's the
unfunded liability the actual
contribution to the pension is less is
is only about a third as much as the
employees are put in so we're expecting
the the employee contribution to be
adjusted downward in the future to make
it more fair and that should apply to
this as well representative gold thank
you madam chair and I apologize to you
if this question is um out of context
but I heard you mention um the
unfunded portion getting paid off in the
future and so I just wanted to ask uh
the H Haner New Hampshire selectman
asked me to uh pay attention to the cost
for the towns for um for these matters
so are you saying that there's something
in this bill that would lower the cost
for
employers no okay there is something in
current
law that says that the employers are
responsible for the unfunded liability
which is a basic part of a defined
benefit plan and that will happen
regardless of whether we pass this bill
or not thank you madam chair and This
only affects state employes EMP es so
that there is no cost or there's no
change to any of the local
employers anyone else represent broa
thank you so um as you know this
committee did a lot of work on House
Bill
436 and as a result of the conversation
that we had between the Senate and the
house on House Bill 436 there was an a
commission formed or committee to look
at the retirement benefits and that is
something that's ongoing and I am not
going to support this bill because I'm
going to wait and see what the
retirement commission recommends and
I'll be attending that meeting tomorrow
thank
you okay
that's it's as far as I can tell the
commission is not considering this sort
of a plan very seriously but it has
certainly been brought up in its on and
it's
within the
scope yes repesent gold just one last
comment that uh for the reason stated by
representative Fitzgerald and thank you
for that Fitzpatrick I'm so sorry thank
you for that I um I I'll be voting yes
on the amendment in the event this gets
passed into law however I won't be
supporting the full Bill thank you
okay anyone else represent black us yeah
i' just like to suggest that we vote on
the amendment um since I think we're
getting to the the rest of the bill in
discussion okay
well okay the motion is to adopt
Amendment
246 to House Bill 559 and the clerk can
call the
role representative Simon yes
representative lakas yes representative
Bailey yes representative Santo naso yes
representative B yes representative Dunn
yes
representative geard yes clerk votes yes
representative
groda vo
oh oh I got these old papers here where
is he right here I put them on the wall
you got CAU from both sides yeah
representative Boyd
yes Representative groa
no representative Schmidt no
representative grassy
yes representative Shu no representative
O'Brien no representative Davis no
representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative G
yes representative Smith
yes Representative mapy
no and the chair
yes 14 y 6
n okay we have adopted the amendment
representative Simon thank you madam
Char I'd like to move otpa on um HB 559
as
amended second by representative
leus sorry is it with Amendment
Amendment with
Amendment we have't amended so it's not
as amended
yes okay is there any uh any do you wish
to speak to your motion um yeah I'll
speak to the motion um you know there's
already been some Lively discussion
today and obviously the last time we had
um this bill before us um and to
representative hes Patrick's um comments
earlier I I feel that um there there is
a great deal of benefit to be considered
when we're looking at a defined
contribution plan as opposed to a
defined benefit plan um and we'd have to
get into probably a fairly lengthy
discussion to cover all those topics
again today um but for me right now of
the more compelling points on the table
uh is that such a large number of the
EMP employees in this particular pool um
we're not talking about group two we're
not even talking about teachers in group
one we're just talking about state
employees in group one and in that pool
of people um the vast majority of them
aren't reaching investment which means
that they're not getting anything out of
their retirement plan and um you know
when we're looking at the argument as to
whether or not the defined benefit plan
is helping with retention which is
another thing that we're giving
consideration to if the vast majority of
those new hires aren't reaching vestment
um that means that they're not hanging
in there very long um and then those
people are walking away with no benefit
at all and so the thing that's
compelling me at the moment is seems to
me if you stick around for three years
5% of your salary is a whole lot more
than 0% of your salary if you stick
around for five years you know um 5% of
five years of your salary is a great
deal more than uh 0% and so forth and so
on all the way up to 9 years of your
salary you could stay for 9 years and
not get any benefit if you're not vested
um and so you know this the main reason
why uh although I know there's
discussion on whether the 5% is is
enough or not uh this bill does not
actually technically limit it to 5% uh
the legislature can always change that
if it decides that more is necessary um
but I just think the upside of this
legislation um is more than the down the
potential downside of the legislation so
uh that's why I'll be supporting it
today
representative leus uh thank
you um so to address some things that
were raised I mean I understand wanting
more money uh 10% would be great but
first of all this is twice what the
employers are currently you know the
state's currently uh
contributing to uh uh the employees
retirement
and you know while there may be
companies that offer that I know in the
Private Industry I'm I've never worked
for one not aware of one that offers um
some offer a little more than 5% I
haven't heard of one that does 10% um so
you know we could argue about just what
what it should be but that seems a
little bit
High um and as the chair said if if uh
hopefully the uh unfunded liability gets
paid off this whole thing can be looked
at
and um you know the employee
contribution could could go down the the
employer contribution could go up uh
there'd be space for that um given that
the unfunded liability wasn't being
being paid for at that time but as
representative Simon said a big thing
for me is that you know with this plan
as soon as the money is put in either by
the employee or the employer that money
belongs to the it's the property of the
employee as well as any gains um that
that uh are developed they become the
property immediately of the
employee I know I don't know if there's
an LSR but I know there's been
discussion about reducing the vesting
periods I've heard numbers like 5 years
um I don't know what percentage of the
employees leave before 5 years but I
know it's even there it's substantial I
just don't know the number uh but that
issue goes away um with a defined
contribution plan because once the
contributions in it belongs the
employee um I mean you know you can
think of all the possible things that
might happen in the future but um
historically I'm not sure there's a
40-year period or almost no 40-year
period in the history of of the the
country
where um you know the gain from you know
a defined contribution plan where it's
invested in in uh just the market uh
would not leave you better off than the
defined benefit plan and um I know for
me and some other people if IID had the
option of uh of uh you know putting my
money into a defined contribution plan
or Define yeah contribution plan rather
than Social Security I certainly would
have jumped on it and um and looking at
history I would be in a a much better
position if that were the case um so and
and the thing is the stock market can go
down things can happen but um you know
retirement savings is retiring for the
long
term um and then there's concern about
employees not being Savvy enough to do a
good job investing um you know the the
uh 401K type programs I'm familiar with
they generally have and this one uh I'm
not sure about the 43b but there's a
default um investment which has a mix of
uh well you know things like stocks and
bonds or long-term things and shorter
term things and that mix changes as the
employees age changes and so that when
you get close to retirement they're put
into uh Investments that are less likely
to be affected by an economic
downturn um but might have lower uh
returns and so you you really want
higher returns earlier in your investing
period than later so you know I think
you know and I ended up having a long
discussion with the state employee union
people uh you know I just see this as
all around a much better deal for the
state employees um and I I uh I didn't
use the word um embarrassing as the two
two and a half% that we're currently
contributing uh but I I would agree with
that um and this would double that um
and move it up into at least um you know
within the reasonable range of what uh
industry offers some are a little more
some a little less I know ones that do a
3% match I worked for one place for
quite a while that did a
6% um again I haven't heard of a 10 um
but um I just think this is um you
know the best thing we can do as far as
Retirement for the employees so thank
you represent Simon thank you madam
chair I I do believe the 403b plan has
that option that you're speaking
of well representative representative
gold let's get some other
people's represent thank you madam chair
if representative leus has an immediate
response oh mine's a different
I just want to explain what the 403b
plan is that is a a defined contribution
plan that's optional uh for state
employees there's no employer match or
no employer contribution but it's a a
tax advantage investment uh offering for
employees and uh uh that's been in place
for a long time that's the four 457 I'm
sorry no I think it was
RSA well I may be wrong never mind yeah
no but there is a state plan that lets
employees contribute um pre-tax for the
retirement and it does offer um you know
the kind of an option that uh adjusts to
your age and does the right thing and
the employee doesn't have to care about
it yes but it it does not include any
employer match correct okay represent
gold on a new topic thank you thank you
madam chair um I just wanted to state
that uh having worked for the state for
and not ever being vested um I can
appreciate the benefits that this
amendment would bring and if I were
doing my typical very independent voting
my own mind I I would likely support
this however I've heard from a great
many of my constituents that they are
not in support of this and um and from
my colleagues here in the committee who
who um understand these matters better
than I do so I will not be voting for
but not based on my own personal opinion
thank you okay anyone else have a
comment representative sh it thank you
madam chair um as I stated before I have
not been in support of this bill all
along uh to me this is basically the
state saying that they are encouraging
their employees to look elsewhere for
employment and I think that's the wrong
direction action for the state to take
um I would also point out that um I'm a
little suspect as to the assurances that
the infrastructure at the retirement
system that supports current employees
would not be damaged by this uh sorry
but I'm not trusting that and I think it
does nothing as we've stated to relieve
the unfunded
liability uh as repres representative
goul says I've heard from many uh
retirees and current
employees that they do not embrace the
tenants of this plan because it assigns
all investment risk to them they would
bear the responsibility for paying all
their health care
premiums and they already have the
Deferred Compensation Plan to add to
their retirement system plan if they so
choose uh I just think that that this
plan erodes whatever trust current
employees have left in our government
entities as
employers and would result in even less
interest in working for the state thank
you okay represent black thank you just
a couple notes one is
um for the employees that move from the
defined benefit to the defined
contribution plan it does still require
the employer to pay
um what their contribution would be to
pay off the past unfunded liability so I
understand there's other concerns but at
least in this that regard it still does
protect um the current pension system um
and the other thing is M someone can
correct me if I'm wrong but I believe
that the uh the current retirement
medical plan is one that's an optional
thing and it's fully funded by the
employees and this bill would permit the
employees in the defined contribution
plan to be part of that if they choose
still so there's no change there I I
don't believe
okay anyone
else all right in that case the motion
is ought to pass with Amendment on House
Bill 559 and the clerk can call the
role representative Simon yes
representative lakus yes representative
Bailey yes representative santonastaso
yes representative B yes representative
Dunn yes
representa ghard yes representative Boyd
yes clerk votes yes representa Gro
no representative Schmidt no
representative grassy no representative
Shu no representative O'Brien no
representative Davis no representative
Fitzpatrick no representative gold no
representative Smith no Representative
manuti no and the chair
yes
101 108 10 n okay not
unexpected uh that will go without
recommendation the minority
recommendation would be itl I presume
yes okay Representatives Simon you have
a committee report in favor of L to pass
with Amendment and who will be doing the
r well put me down for it we'll figure
some we'll figure something out
okay okay all right that is our last
bill for the year we have completed all
of 2023 thank you all very
much thank you mad exactly it's been
it's been a slog uh there are quite a
lot of bills that or lsrs that look like
they might be headed our way if you
would uh devote your copious free time
in the late in December to looking at
the one at at them once they come out as
bills if you can identify any that
are poised to go to Edna that you just
as rather not or think they shouldn't be
I'll try and get them vacated to
somebody else and um otherwise
read up on them because it's going to be
a fun year next year representative
Schmidt thank you madam chair and uh I
express my personal gratitude to all the
substitutes who are here today and I
know you're going to be looking into
finding out whom we are getting as
a
semi-permanent nobody nobody's permanent
uh semi-permanent uh replacements for
the people we losing representative
grassier are going off to higher higher
and better things for
sure so thank you for your time with us
for the past couple of months much
appreciated and good luck on having um a
different uh outcome than last night
gave you on the city council you
certainly have set a record in
tying for a second time in a
row un it shows that your constituents
really are
everye matter and the thing is madam
chers I don't think they're they're
split you know ideologically they want
both of us
oh that's the problem that's a challenge
to implement yeah yeah and and for your
planning purposes uh we will be meeting
on Wednesdays and some Thursdays next
week with Fridays and
Mondays possible but not not likely oh
you
say no no no end next year starting in
January we'll be meeting Wednesdays for
sure Thursdays when we don't have
session and possibly Mondays or Fridays
although I will try not to need
them those of us who've been around for
a long time remember a radio program
called the
shadow um and so representative Gro has
not learned to Cloud men's or women's
mind so that they cannot see her so I
noticed that she came in and placed a
carton of some something on the table
and I'm a little bit curious we are
celebrating representative shu's
survival to another year
ah with Grace and and
honor and and it's a nice way to end our
year I will
say